In diesem Sommer werden zwei Bücher erscheinen von Frauen, die jeweils ihren Weg im Fußball gegangen sind und das trockts aller strukturellen Nachteile, die man als Frau im Fußballgeschäft noch hat. Wir wollen heute darüber sprechen mit Lena Cassel, die über die Regionalliga bei Fortuna Köln bis in die Primetime es geschafft hat. Ihr kennt sie ja vielleicht aus dem Mainzer Keller und dem Rasenfunk, aber ganz sicher auch von The Zone und Amazon Prime und wir wollen sprechen mit Kathrin Längert. Auch sie hatten wir, muss ich sagen, die Ehre auch schon hier im Rasenfunk zu haben. Sie hat es bis hin zum unter anderem DFB-Pokalsieg mit den Bayern-Frauen geschafft, aber hatte noch so viele interessante Stationen auch drum herum. Unter anderem war sie auch Torhüter-Trainerin vom Nationalteam der Frauen Saudi Arabiens. Also ihr könnt euch auf diese Folge wirklich freuen. Das Verbindende zwischen den beiden ist nicht nur die Liebe zum Fußball, sondern noch viel, viel mehr. Jetzt starten wir rein. Viel Spaß bei dieser Sendung.
Betrifft natürlich auch noch ganz viele andere Sportarten. Also ich sehe schon die Kommentare vor mir, die darauf hinweisen, in anderen Sportarten ist es noch viel schlimmer. Das stimmt, aber wir reden jetzt eben gerade über die eine Sportart, die sich in Deutschland aus ganz vielen Gründen durchgesetzt hat und in der irre viel Geld unterwegs ist. Deswegen hat es dann halt dann doch nochmal, glaube ich, eine andere Bedeutung, wenn wir jetzt über Fußball sprechen und nicht über Handball, Eishockey, Basketball, Volleyball und so weiter.
Ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen Whataboutism. Also ich bin total solidarisch mit allen meinen Kollegen in den anderen Sportarten. Ich habe ja auch viele von denen kennengelernt im Olympiastützpunkt in München. Wir haben uns ja da eine Physiotherapie geteilt und die Krafträume und so. Ganz tolle Athletinnen. Ich habe mich auch immer mega geschämt, wenn ihr alle erzählt haben, wie viel die trainieren, weil niemand so wenig trainiert, glaube ich, wie Fußballerinnen. Ja, wirklich. Also ganz krass, was die da für 400 Euro Sporthilfe und irgendwie eine Stelle beim Zoll leisten. Aber genau wie du sagst, wir können halt immer nur ein Thema nach dem anderen behandeln. Und dafür bin ich halt nicht Expertin, aber dass generell der Sport in Deutschland unterfinanziert ist, ist auch ein offenes Geheimnis. Und dass du für eine Goldmedaille 20.000 Euro vor Steuern kriegst, ist genauso eine Frechheit.
Lena, wie war denn da dein Weg? Also ich meine, man kann es ja sehr schön bei dir nachlesen. Da hat auch ein Zugausfall eine wichtige Rolle gespielt, muss man sagen. Und du hast dann irgendwann auch eine andere Entscheidung getroffen. Aber was würdest du sagen, war im Nachhinein das größte strukturelle Hindernis, über das du springen musstest?
Ich glaube, das, was Kathrin Schuh gesagt hat, wichtiger Aspekt, die soziale Herkunft, das Elternhaus, was sich natürlich dann schon auch unterstützt, was sich finanziell auch auffangen kann, das war bei mir nicht gegeben. Primär war bei mir relativ schnell klar, mit 17, als ich ausgezogen bin, ich muss Geld verdienen und ich muss arbeiten und ich muss mich irgendwie selber finanzieren, weil ich kein soziales Netz hatte, was mich in der Form dann auffangen kann, um meinen Traum zu verwirklichen. Also klar, vielleicht hätte es jetzt auch vom Talent her nicht ganz für die Bundesliga gereicht.
Du hast aus 200 Metern ein Wolle-Tor geschossen, habe ich gelesen.
Danke, dass du das erwähnst, Max. Danke, dass du das noch mal erwähnst. Aber die 2. Bundesliga war durchaus zeitweise ein Thema. Du hast den Edvigenwechsel zum 1. FC Köln ja schon angesprochen, wo ich leider nie ankam beim Probetraining, weil die Deutsche Bahn nicht weiterfuhr. Ich saß in einem schneebedeckten Zug fest und habe das Probetraining verpasst. Ich bin ja wahnsinnig abergläubisch und habe dann es so für mich verargumentiert. Vermutlich hatte ich aber auch nur einfach Schiss. Habe gesagt, es soll nicht sein. Ich werde nicht zum ersten FC Köln-Probetraining gehen. Ich werde kein neues Verein bahnen. Und irgendwann kam dann aber der SV Fortuna Köln um die Ecke und wollte mich sozusagen haben. Ich habe ja damals noch in der Verbandsliga gespielt. Bei einem Dorfverein namens SV Elner Bödingen. Ich habe da sechs Jahre lang gespielt. Und der SV Fortuna Köln wollte mich also haben. Und der SV Elner Bödingen hat gesagt, naja, ihr könnt Lena haben, aber wir wollen eine Ausbildungsentschädigung dafür haben. Denn die Spielerin, die Lena jetzt ist, haben wir ausgebildet. Das bedeutete, der SV Elner Bödingen wollte eine Ablöse von mir haben. Also für mich haben es 500 Euro. 500 Euro, die ich dem SV Fortuna Köln allerdings nicht wert war, weil sie keine Ablöse für Spielerinnen bezahlen. Die Betonung liegt da auf Innen, weil für Männer bezahlen sie den natürlich, aber halt nicht für Frauen, weil kein Budget-Top dafür da sei. Long story short, ich musste also meine Ablöse, wenn ich zum SV Fortuna Köln hätte wechseln wollen, selber aufbringen. Also ich musste mich also selber kaufen. Findet mal 500 Euro als Anfang 20-Jährige, als Studentin, die wirklich jeden Cent umdrehen musste, war schwierig. Ein Finanzier tauchte dann dennoch auf. Es war mein Opa Herbert, der die 500 Euro Ablöse für mich bezahlte und somit konnte ich zum SV Fortuna Köln wechseln, allerdings auch ohne Vertrag. Also ich habe keinen Amateurvertrag bekommen, obwohl wir in der dritten Liga gespielt haben, in der Regionalliga. Ich habe kein Geld bekommen, ich hatte keine Versicherung, ich hatte gar nichts. Ich habe aber dennoch vier bis fünf Mal die Woche dort auf dem Trainingsplatz gestanden, Auswärtsfahrten organisiert am Sonntag, der ganze Tag war weg. Und irgendwann habe ich aber dann angefangen, bei der Sportschau zu arbeiten und habe auch vorher nebenbei immer gearbeitet. Und die Sportschau-Zeiten, die kollidierten aber eben mit diesem Sonntag 15 Uhr, wo eben der Frauenfußball gespielt hat, mit den Zeiten der Männer Bundesliga, wo ich dann für die Sportschau im Einsatz war. Das bedeutet also, ich musste teilweise nach der ersten Halbzeit gehen, weil ich arbeiten musste bei der Sportschau. Und mein Trainer sagte dann irgendwann zu mir, Lena, ich kann dich eigentlich auch nicht mehr aufstellen, weil mit dir habe ich direkt einen Wechsel verloren, weil du in der Halbzeit immer weggehen musst zum Arbeiten. Das wird ein Problem werden. Also musste ich mich irgendwann entscheiden. Ich musste mich entscheiden zwischen meiner semiprofessionellen Fußballkarriere und meiner Karriere oder dem Geldverdienen bei der Sportschau. Und dann habe ich mich für die Sportschau entschieden und gegen meine semiprofessionelle Fußballkarriere, weil ich auf der einen Seite Geld verdienen musste und auf der anderen Seite eben kein Geld verdient habe mit dem Fußballspielen, sondern eben nur mit dem bei der Sportschau arbeiten. Und das waren die Hürden, mit denen ich zu kämpfen hatte, warum ich dann eventuell nicht den Sprung in die zweite Bundesliga geschafft habe, weil es nicht anders möglich war. Und das sind dann, glaube ich, die Geschichten, die du nur im Fußball der Frauen findest und nicht im Fußball der Männer findest, weil du da in der dritten Liga schon einen vierstelligen Betrag mindestens verdienst, der dir zumindest die Miete und eventuell auch das Auto bezahlen kann. Und das ist im Fußball der Frauen eben ganz, ganz anders. Also ich habe in der Regionalliga West gespielt und ich habe keinen einzigen Cent verdient.
Ja und ich finde, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, den du da nennst, weil wir haben darüber gesprochen, dass wir ganz viele Mädchen nicht erreichen, weil die gar nicht mit Fußball anfangen können. Aber ich glaube, wir haben vergessen zu erwähnen, wie viele wir zwischendurch verlieren. Weil sie im Fußball nicht bleiben können. Weil sich eben, weil sich für Frauen viel zu oft Scheidewege auf tun, wo du dich entscheiden musst. Gehe ich jetzt studieren oder spiele ich Fußball? Für mich war es zum Beispiel auch, als das Angebot kam, als ich, ich glaube, als ich 14 war, als das Angebot aus Duisburg kam, ob ich halt für die in der Jugend spielen will. Ich habe halt vorher in Essen gespielt. Die haben einmal weniger die Woche trainiert. Die haben halt in der zweiten Liga gespielt. Duisburg hat erste Liga gespielt und dreimal die Woche dann trainiert. Und da war dann so das erste Mal schon, wo ich mich so entscheiden musste, möchte ich das jetzt hier leistungsmäßig weiterführen, möchte ich Richtung, also versuchen weit zu kommen, möchte ich versuchen, das zu schaffen. Und das ging eben nur, weil klar war, meine Eltern können mich dreimal die Woche fahren. Oder dann später auch. Mendy Islaka kommt ja zum Glück auch aus Essen, zum Beispiel. Dass klar war, es gibt mehr Mädchen aus Essen. Wir können, wir haben eine Fahrgemeinschaft, wir kommen dahin. Ja, und solche Wegmarker kommen halt immer wieder. Und noch in meiner aktiven Zeit, ich habe ja auch erst 2017 aufgehört, hattest du immer wieder Spielerinnen, vor allem in kleinen Vereinen, die mit Mitte 20 aufgehört haben, weil dann das Studium vorbei war, oder die in ihrer Firma inzwischen ganz gut etabliert waren nach der Ausbildung und für die klar war, die können jetzt da einfach auch deutlich mehr Geld verdienen. Ich muss das so sagen, ich habe ja auch studiert, wäre ich mit Mitte 20 ins Lehramt gegangen, ich hätte mehr Geld verdient als als Fußball-Nationalspielerin. Ich hätte einfach mehr Netto gehabt. Ich habe Geld verloren und auch Karrierechancen jetzt nach dem Fußball, weil man ja zehn Jahre später einsteigt als alle anderen. Ja, also ich habe wirtschaftlichen Schaden erlitten, weil ich eine Fußballkarriere bis zu Ende durchgespielt habe. Und es ist im Traineramt übrigens überhaupt nicht anders. Also wir kommen jetzt ja dann auch dahin, dass der DFB alles professionalisieren will und dann sagt, so ab jetzt sind alle TrainerInnen in Vollzeit. Da möchte ich gerne mal fragen, wie viel ist denn Vollzeit? Weil ich habe schon einen Job angeboten bekommen in der ersten Bundesliga. Ich sage jetzt nicht, bei welchem Club. Es war nicht Essen als Torwart-Trainerin für 1200 Netto. So und ich verdiene aber als Lehrerin deutlich, deutlich mehr. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, warum sollte ich mich dann entscheiden, Vollzeit als Torwart-Trainerin zu arbeiten, wenn ich in einem anderen Beruf meinen Lebensunterhalt besser leisten kann? Plus Vereinbarkeit Familie und Beruf. Ich bin jetzt ja auch noch Mutter geworden. Ich habe jetzt noch nicht die Regularien gefunden, die mir jetzt irgendwie absichern, wer eine Betreuungsperson bezahlt, wer das Familienzimmer bezahlt, wie ich mit einem Baby zu einem Auswärtsspiel reisen kann. Also diese ganzen Aspekte von Zugang, von Sichtbarkeit, von auch Absicherung. Lena hat ja zu Recht gesagt, sie hatte auch gar keine Versicherung. Ja, was passiert, wenn du dir da das Knie zerfetzt und danach musst du noch 40 Jahre als Physiotherapeutin arbeiten? Also es gibt so viele Unsicherheiten für uns, die immer wieder dafür sorgen, dass sich Frauen dagegen entscheiden müssen, weil es einfach keinen Sinn macht oder sie es einfach nicht mehr leisten können, weil die Belastung auch so unglaublich hoch ist, wenn du denn wirklich deine ganze Sportkarriere lang doppelt und dreifach arbeitest.
Und das ist eben auch wirklich kein zu unterschätzender Punkt, nicht nur eben wegen der Spielerinnenbiografien. Also das ist ja wirklich, das kannst du ja eigentlich auf einen Witz zusammenfassen. Bei den Männern, wenn du mit ihnen sprichst, warum bist denn du kein Profifußballer, dann war es immer die Knieverletzung. Natürlich der einzige Grund. Und bei Frauen ist es ja, ich musste halt irgendwann arbeiten oder Geld verdienen, weil es nicht mehr anders ging. Es war nicht mehr miteinander vereinbar. Aber es ist insofern auch ein wichtiger Punkt, weil wir hier ja auch durchaus uns in der rechtlichen Grauzone bewegen. Also die Spielerinnen-Verträge, die es dann gibt und nicht alle unterschreiben ja überhaupt welche und die Vereine wissen genau, warum nicht alle einen unterschreiben. Weil du kommst dann nämlich ganz schnell in die Mindestlohn-Debatte rein, wo du dann nämlich feststellen musst, bei dem Aufwand, den Spielerinnen betreiben, um ihrem Sport nachzugehen, landen die bei einem Mindestlohn. Da kannst du froh sein, wenn der bei 4 oder 5 Euro ist, aber nicht bei den 12 Euro irgendwas, die er sein sollte. Und das ist durchaus auch juristisch ein Thema. Ich habe mal einen O-Ton, den ich dann hier einspielen möchte. Das ist aus einem Sport-and-Side-Beitrag von Markus Barg. Das ist der Jurist Philipp S. Fischinger. Der hat da kurz auf die Frage geantwortet, wann müsste man denn eigentlich nach Mindestlohn bezahlt werden?
Es ist letztlich immer eine Frage des Einzelfalls. Man müsste sich alle Faktoren anschauen. Das muss man klar betonen. Allerdings, wer im Prinzip genötigt ist, regelmäßig zum Training zu kommen, dem vorgegeben wird, wann er trainiert, was er trainiert, wo er trainiert, ob er spielt, wie er spielt. Das spricht sehr viel für die Arbeitnehmer-Eigenschaft. Die Folge wäre dann, dass die Chancen für die Klage gut wären.
Jetzt möchte ich mal ganz kurz wissen, wer von denjenigen, der das gerade gehört hat, nicht gesagt hat, uns wurde gesagt, wo wir trainieren, wann wir trainieren, wie wir trainieren. Meine These dazu, das ist ein riesiges Thema, das sehr selten aufgebohrt wird. Und gleichzeitig ist das ja nur die eine Ebene. Wir haben die finanzielle Entschädigung, die braucht man und die ist auch richtig und die soll da sein. Und wenn es so wäre, dass man nach Leistung verdient, müssten eigentlich die Frauen, die nebenher noch eine Ausbildung, ein Studium, einen Beruf ausüben, mehr verdienen als die Männer, die in Anführungszeichen nur Leistungssportler sind. Aber das andere ist ja, und das hast du gerade angesprochen Kathrin, dass man ja auch, wenn man Leistungssport betreibt, dann ist das nicht so, wie wenn ich kicken gehe. Da tut mir danach ein bisschen, tut mir alles weh, weil ich bin nicht mehr durchtrainiert und so weiter und so fort. Aber man betreibt Raubbau am eigenen Körper. Und was du geschrieben hast in deinem Buch zu den medizinischen Angeboten, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man es Angebot nennen sollte, die du in deiner Profikarriere hast, das war eigentlich, finde ich, mit der Erschütterungste. Dabei wusste ich davon einiges ja schon. Du warst ja schon bei Mara im Podcast. Wir haben schon drüber gesprochen. Aber kannst du noch mal kurz für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das Buch noch nicht gelesen haben und es danach aber bitte noch tun, noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, was ist denn dir in deiner Karriere überhaupt passiert an gesundheitlichem Schaden, der dir vielleicht für immer in deinem Leben bleiben wird?
Ja, das ist wirklich eine ganz wichtige Debatte, die oft zu kurz kommt. Es wird immer so prominent dieses Equal Pay-Thema platziert. Und das hat auch eine Berechtigung, weil ich fordere im Buch ja unter anderem auch einen Mindestlohn und erkläre auch, warum es den geben muss. Aber die Spielerinnen weisen ja in Interviews auch oft auf dieses Equal-Play-Thema hin. Und mir war ganz wichtig, in dem Buch diese drei Hauptkapitel mal aufzumachen. Equal Pay, Equal Play und der DFB. Also was macht der Verband, der für unseren Spielbetrieb ja immer noch hauptverantwortlich ist? Weil das eben die Themen sind, die in den Medien manchmal vorkommen, aber wo irgendwie im direkten Gespräch, ich oft merke, die Leute haben gar nicht so richtig Ahnung, was dahinter steckt, was die jetzt genau meinen. Und das Medizinenthema ist ein Aspekt eben des Equal Plays, wo, glaube ich, die allgemeine Vorstellung ist, weil wir eben den Männerfußball so gut kennen und der so groß präsentiert ist, dass dann die Spieler nach dem Training sich auf die Massagebank legen und dann wird dann groß ausmassiert und nach dem Spiel geht es irgendwie in die Eistonne, ins Entmüdungsbecken. Und das sind alles Bedingungen, die wir einfach nicht hatten. Also wir hatten so, ich sage mal, die Standardfrage bei jedem Training war, ist heute ein Physio da? Damit geht es ja schon mal los. Ich meine, Lena wird es noch viel schlimmer erlebt haben in der Regionalliga. Aber selbst beim FC Bayern war es jetzt halt so, ist heute ein Physio da? Also es war nicht mal bei jedem Training medizinisches Personal vor Ort. Es gab dann vielleicht einen Medizinkoffer in der Kabine. Dann hat man sich halt selber getapet. Ich kann so gut tapen für jemanden, der gar keine medizinische Ausbildung hat. Ich kann alle. Ich kann Sprunggelenke. Ich kann Hände. Ich kann auch Kinesio-Tape. Muskulatur, kein Problem, Knie. Wir haben uns einfach gegenseitig getapet. Gut war immer, wenn eine eine Ausbildung zur Physiotherapeutin gemacht hat, dann hattest du schon mal eine mit Expertise. Aber die Arme war ja eigentlich da, um Fußball zu spielen, um ihren Job zu machen und wurde dann bei den Auswärtsspielen noch als Physiotherapeutin missbraucht. Die konnte sich gar nicht aufs Spiel konzentrieren. Die musste erst mal noch vier Leute vorversorgen, damit es halt losgehen kann. Was ich im Endeffekt auch sagen kann, glaube ich, ist, dass mich zumindest teilweise auch die medizinische Unterversorgung vielleicht ein paar Karrierejahre gekostet hat. Muss man einfach so sagen. Ich meine, da haben auch andere Faktoren reingespielt. Ich war immer brutal übergeizig. Ich habe mich mit Sicherheit auch nicht immer an die vorgegebenen Regenerationszeiten gehalten. Aber es gab auch viel Druck von außen, muss man auch sagen. Natürlich immer zu spielen, sich immer irgendwie auch krank noch auf den Platz zu stellen, mit einer Verletzung vielleicht eine Woche früher zu probieren, weil das Spiel ist wichtig und wir haben sonst keinen. Aber am Ende des Tages habe ich mit 30 aufgehört und ich hatte eine Hüftverletzung, Adduktorenverletzung am Ende. Ich weiß es bis heute nicht, weil es halt nicht richtig diagnostiziert wurde. Unser Physiotherapeut in Jena damals war glaube ich im ersten Lehrjahr. Wir hatten ganz oft auch Auszubildende als Physiotherapeutinnen, weil die halt einfach billiger waren. Die wurden doch genauso ausgebeutet. Da ist dann einer für 50 Euro dreimal die Woche gekommen und hat irgendwie 100 Kilometer Busfahrt am Wochenende mitgemacht, weil es für die halt ein großes Sprungbrett war. Erfahrung zu sammeln und irgendwie in der Sportphysiotherapie Karriere zu machen. Wir hatten auch super, super viele sehr gute Physiotherapeuten, aber die waren dann oft in externen Praxen angestellt. Da musstest du dir ein Rezept besorgen beim Mannschaftsarzt und bist dann zusätzlich zu deiner Belastung mit Arbeit, Schule oder Training halt dann noch privat hingefahren in deiner Freizeit und hast dich da behandeln lassen, hast dich da tapen lassen. Und ich hatte eben zum Schluss eine schwierige Hüftverletzung, eine Adduktorenverletzung. Ich konnte nicht mehr schießen, das ist jetzt als Fußballspielerin relativ schwierig, auch als Torhüterin und bin ein halbes Jahr ausgefallen. Ich weiß bis heute nicht warum quasi, ich hatte einfach jeden Tag Schmerzen, ich konnte nicht mal gehen und konnte das dann in einer langen Reha-Phase, in der Sommerpause noch mal halbwegs stabilisieren. Ich bin dann noch mal eingestiegen zur Saison 16, 17, am ersten Spiel darin Leverkusen gespielt. Ich habe sogar ein richtig gutes Spiel gemacht, ich war total erleichtert, weil es ja mein erstes Pflichtspiel dann auch für Jena war. Die hatten ja auch große Hoffnung, glaube ich, in mich gesetzt oder in meine Verpflichtung. Und irgendwann in der zweiten Halbzeit musste ich einen langen Ball, der hinter die Kette gespielt wurde, halt klären, habe den weggeschossen, habe die Stelle gemerkt und dann wusste ich halt, okay, das war's. Also ich wusste eigentlich am ersten Spieltag quasi schon, das ist meine letzte Saison, weil ich wusste, wenn das jetzt nicht weg ist, nach sechs Monaten Reha, ich habe alles probiert, ich war in externen Kliniken, ich war im Wasserbecken mit den Omas morgens um sieben, habe Aquagymnastik gemacht, ich wusste dann, dann wird es nie mehr ganz weggehen und ist es auch nicht. Also und das ist halt so was, wo ich sage, ich kann noch nicht mal bei der BG Ansprüche stellen, weil ich habe gar keine MRT Bilder.
Also bei der Berufsgenossenschaft.
Ja genau, sorry, wir haben ja über Versicherungsschutz auch gesprochen. Jetzt bin ich zwar Lehrkraft, also ich habe Glück, ich habe Deutsch und Englisch studiert, aber wenn ich jetzt Sportlehrerin wäre, ich habe Kolleginnen, die hatten drei Kreuzbandrisse, die haben dann bei der Verbeamtung schon mal die eine oder andere Extrauntersuchung und müssen auch da Angst haben, dass es halt Konsequenzen für ihre weitere Berufslaufbahn hat. Also diese medizinische Unterversorgung sorgt dafür, dass es für uns Frauen viel wahrscheinlicher ist, dass du irreparable Schäden mitnimmst in die Zeit nach deiner Karriere, die dich dann nicht nur gesundheitlich beeinträchtigen, sondern die dich auch eventuell in deinem weiteren Berufsweg hindern, weil nochmal, auch wenn du die Knöchel kaputt hast und hast dann Physiotherapeutin gelernt oder hast Friseurin gelernt und hast halt was, wo du stehen musst, das hat alles Auswirkungen und auch die 40 Jahre danach kompensiert dir ja keiner, weil du hast ja einfach finanziell nicht ausgesorgt. Du musst mit diesem Körper danach noch ganz regulär arbeiten, wie alle anderen deutschen ArbeitnehmerInnen auch und ja, das ist halt was, wo ich weiß, dass es deutlich besser geworden ist, müssen wir sagen. Viele Vereine haben da einen großen Schritt nach vorne gemacht, aber spätestens, wenn wir in Liga 2 gucken, weiß ich schon, da ist dann wieder, da ist dann wieder nada so und da wird dann wieder einfach Ibuprofen genommen vor dem Spiel, um zu gucken, ob es geht. Aber da fehlt einfach medizinische Infrastruktur, um diesen Frauen auch gerecht zu werden. Und da sind wir noch nicht dabei, dass Menstruation immer noch völlig unerforscht ist und unser Zyklus keine Rolle spielt bei der Trainingsplanung.
Und vor allen Dingen, wenn du über das Thema Equal Play sprichst und dass die Spielerinnen das fordern, so auf dieser ganz unterschwelligen Ebene, ist es dann zumindest abgesichert zu sein. Genau dann, wenn du dich verletzt, dass du einen Amateurvertrag hast und damit eben auch Anspruch auf eventuell eine verletzte Rente, so nennt man das, also wenn du später nämlich bleibende Schäden hast, dass du dann auch eine Entschädigung bekommst, weil du dich eben bei deiner Arbeit verletzt hast. Und wenn du keinen Vertrag hast, da geht es noch nicht mal darum, dass du da wirklich Unsummen an Geld verdienst, sondern es geht um schlicht und ergreifende Absicherung, weil das nun mal ein Kontaktsport ist, wo auch unter anderem Frauen, die auf schlechteren Plätzen spielen, wo die Menstruation nicht mit einberechnet worden ist, wo du gar nicht weißt, was dein Zyklus eventuell auch für eine Auswirkung auf eventuelle Verletzungsanfälligkeit hat. Es gibt ja mittlerweile auch eine Korrelation zwischen Kreuzbandrissen und dem Zyklus. Das ist alles nicht erforscht. Das heißt, Frauen brauchen eigentlich noch einen höheren Schutz als Männer in diesem Sport, weil sie eben natürlich unterversorgt sind, weil es eben nicht die Infrastruktur gibt. Das heißt, der Bedarf eines Vertrages ist noch viel größer als der bei den Männern. Darum ging es mir eben auch bei meiner Drittligatätigkeit da als Spielerin von Fortuna Köln, dass ich einfach mich einem Verletzungsrisiko ausgesetzt habe und ich einfach nicht abgesichert war. Das war auch ein Aspekt neben dem, dass ich halt Geld verdienen musste, dass ich einfach Sorge hatte, mich zu verletzen, dementsprechend auch nicht mehr arbeitsfähig gewesen wäre. Ich muss in meinem Job sehr viel reisen und ich auch keine Entschädigung bekommen hätte. Und wir hatten zahlreiche Polizistinnen bei uns in der Mannschaft. Wenn sie ein Kreuzbanddres haben, die waren nicht mehr einsatzfähig. Und da hat dann teilweise auch der Arbeitgeber gesagt, wir verbieten dir das Fußballspielen, weil du dich einem solchen Verletzungsrisiko aussetzt. Du bist nicht abgesichert. Das können wir so nicht mehr leisten. Das ist nicht mehr tragbar. Und das sind natürlich Themen, die gar nicht so in dieser Debatte besprochen werden, weil immer ja primär nur über dieses Equal Pay Thema gesprochen wird, was wieder nur von der Spitze gedacht ist. Aber wir müssen da viel rudimentärer drüber reden, was das im Day by Day bei allen Spielerinnen auf der nicht super professionellen Ebene, sondern auf der semi professionellen Ebene bedeutet. Und wenn du über physiotherapeutische Behandlung sprichst, das sah bei uns so aus, dass wir einen kleinen Medizinkoffer hatten und darin war ein nasser Schwamm und eine kleine Flasche mit Wasser. Das war physiotherapeutische Behandlung.
Ja, ich muss so lachen, weil ich war ja auch Trainerin in der Jugend und die SGS Jugend hat ja in der Bundesliga auch gespielt, höchste Jugendliga, U17 Bundesliga. Und wir hatten dann tatsächlich in einer Saison den Fall, dass die Physiotherapeutin mitten in der Saison gekündigt hat, nämlich genau weil die ihre Abschlussprüfung hatte für ihre Ausbildung. Die war auch eine Auszubildende. Und dann hatten wir einfach bei jedem Spiel diesen Koffer dabei, wo ein trockener Schwamm drin lag. Das war alles, weil wir waren halt nur drei Trainerinnen, keine von uns hatte Ahnung. Und wir haben einfach immer so wirklich wie ein Placebo, wo so pro forma diesen leeren Koffer dahingestellt. Aber wenn sich eine verletzte, hat es nicht mehr passiert, als dass die Co-Trainerin hingerannt ist, hat die so ein bisschen über den Kopf gestrichen und gesagt, ist okay, geht wieder oder soll man mal kurz rausgehen. So das war dann halt die medizinische Versorgung. Und es ist so wichtig, dass du auch nochmal gesagt hast, wie das alles miteinander verzahnt ist. Ich habe dann im Buch da auch verschiedene Beispiele zu aufgeführt, auch zu Trainingsbedingungen, weil genau weil wir schlechtere Plätze haben, ist das Verletzungsrisiko höher. Wenn du dich verletzt, dann springt aber ja zum Beispiel nach, ich weiß nicht, sechs Wochen oder so, kriegst du ja dann nur noch kranken Tage Geld. Dann hast du, weil du so wenig Geld kriegst, auf einmal noch viel, viel weniger Geld. Also es war wirklich existenziell manchmal, wenn du dann auf dieses kranken Tage Geld gekommen bist, hattest du so wenig Netto im Monat, dass es schon wieder schwierig wurde mit Miete und Auto und allem. Und dann geht man schon mal eine Woche früher wieder zurück ins Mannschaftstraining. Also man darf wirklich nicht vergessen, für wie viele es dann auch existenziell wird. Und wenn wir beim Thema Zyklus sind, es ist ja nicht nur dieses Nischenthema nicht erforscht, sondern in der gesamten Sportwissenschaft ist meines Wissens nach, sind die meisten Studien, die meisten Trainingsempfehlungen alles basiert auf dem männlichen Körper. Ich denke, ich frage mich manchmal auch, ob wir so viele Kreuzbandrisse bei den Frauen erleben, weil die ganze Sportwissenschaft, die ganzen Trainingsumfänge auf männliche Körper ausgelegt sind. Es hat sich, glaube ich, niemals ernsthaft jemand damit beschäftigt, wie sollte denn die Saisonvorbereitung für Frauen aussehen. Und zwar nicht nur fußballspezifisch, sondern eben auch im Athletiktraining, in der Sportmedizin, alles ist am männlichen Körper erforscht.
Auch die Ausstattung, Fußballschuhe, Sport-BHs. Wir haben ja auch eine ganz andere Physiognomie, dadurch, dass wir Brüste haben. Guess what? Das heißt, wir haben eine ganz andere körperliche Ausstattung. Also brauchen wir auch eine andere Ausstattung eventuell, die uns schützt vor Verletzungen. Das sind Themen, die einfach nicht besprochen werden.
Ich glaube, wir sind massiv übertrainiert und massiv unterversorgt. In der Breite und auch noch in vielen Teilen der Spitze. Und da besteht so eine große Datenlücke, dass ich anstelle des DFB auch da als Erstes in Forschung investieren würde, weil wenn mir bei jedem Turnier vier Topspielerinnen mit Verletzungen fehlen, dann und auch natürlich die Vereine, auch in FC Bayern, auch in VfL Wolfsburg. Da wäre ich ja froh, wenn mir zum Saisonfinale die besten Frauen auch zur Verfügung stehen. Das wäre mir wirklich wert, dass sich in dem Bereich was tut, weil ich glaube, wir wissen gar nicht, unter welchen Bedingungen der weibliche Körper die besten Leistungen bringen kann, weil sich dann noch nie jemand ernsthaft mit beschäftigt hat.
Und interessanterweise landet man immer beim DFB. Der DFB würde jetzt dann sagen, ja, es ist Aufgabe der Vereine, die unterstützen wir dabei und so weiter und so fort. Und letztlich ist aber immer die Frage, von welcher Seite des Spektrums möchte man ein Problem angehen? Vorhin haben wir schon gesagt, es wäre viel wichtiger in die Basis zu investieren als eben in den Spitzensport. Und jetzt sind wir ja aber in einem Bereich, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, vielleicht ist es hier jetzt dann umgedreht, dass man über Erkenntnisse, die man im absoluten Top-Segment erreicht, durch eine bessere Versorgung, durch eine bessere Studienlage, dann Erkenntnisse gewinnt, die man dann auch runterbringen kann, bis aufs Abateur-Level über die Liegen hinweg, über zum Beispiel auch Trainingsmaterialien. Das beschreibst du ja auch sehr schön in deinem Buch, Kathrin, dass ja Frauen gar nicht vorkommen in den Lizenzen vom DFB, wo ich vorher nicht drüber nachgedacht habe. Klar, ich bin ja ein Typ, wir denken oft über solche Dinge nicht nach. Aber das ist ja völlig absurd. Also das ist ja an Absurdität nicht zu überbieten, dass Frauen nicht mal, also auf keiner Folie, du hast es in einem Beispiel genannt, 168 Seiten Material. Keine einzige Frau ist überhaupt nur abgebildet. Aber das wäre jetzt dann meine Frage an dich, Kathrin. Wäre das dann vielleicht der Punkt, wo man sagen wirst, okay, hier setzen wir jetzt dann oben an und fangen im Leistungssport an, machen da die Studien, verbessern dort die Bedingungen und dann kann das vielleicht sich nach unten durchsetzen?
Absolut, weil da sind die Ressourcen vorhanden, da sind die Spielerinnen vorhanden, da ist die Zeit vorhanden. Da würde ich sagen, muss die Forschung quasi in der Spitze anfangen. Das müssen ja nicht nur Top-Vereine der ersten Bundesliga sein. Ich denke auch ganz oft zum Beispiel an Jugend-Nationalmannschaften, weil der DFB Ressourcen hat, weil eben, wie gesagt, ich davon überzeugt bin, dass viele Universitäten gerne mit dem DFB kooperieren würden, um sowas zu erforschen, weil wir ja eben auch die Erkenntnisse gerade im Jugendbereich brauchen, wo die körperliche Entwicklung noch nicht abgeschlossen ist. Ja, also ich beschreibe das ja im Buch, wenn es um diese Folien geht, dann ging es zum Beispiel unter anderem darum, dass wir im Torwarttrainerlehrgang die Entwicklungsstufen präsentiert haben für die Teilnehmenden. Also welche Entwicklungsstufen durchlaufen. Spieler, muss man in dem Moment ja sagen. Wann ist was gefragt? Wann sind die körperlich wie weit? Und ich habe mir das halt angeschaut und dachte mir, das stimmt aber überhaupt nicht für Mädchen. Unsere Pubertät entwickelt sich ganz anders. Und wir haben dann durch die Periode noch mal einen besonderen Einschnitt und wir haben körperlich eben zum Beispiel nicht diese Wachstumsschubprobleme, wo ich so dachte, für uns kann das gar nicht passen. Und da würde ich wirklich sagen, würde ich die Forschung in der Spitze ansetzen und die Erkenntnisse dann zum Beispiel durch die Trainerinnen-Lehrgänge in die Breite bringen. Weil das sind Menschen, die sind hauptberuflich Dachdecker, die können jetzt nicht noch irgendwie 15 Paper lesen in ihrer Freizeit, wie jetzt gerade die Lage ist. Sondern da würde ich mir wünschen, dass das dann vernünftig aufbereitet wird. Vom DFB geht das ja an die Landesverbände und da bringen das dann die Referenten in die untersten Amateurlizenzen. Jeder, der Kreisliga-Trainer sein will, muss eine C-Lizenz machen. Und da kann man sowas super in so einem Theorie-Blog präsentieren. Das ist jetzt im Moment die Lage, wenn ihr eine Frauenmannschaft trainiert, achtet in der Vorbereitung darauf, dass ihr eben, wir haben jetzt keine Erkenntnisse, random Beispiel, dass ihr eben den Lauftest montags macht. Aber wenn dann eben Leute ihre Periode haben, dann lasst die lieber erst freitags laufen. Und die können dann separat aber das und das schon machen. Ja, die können vielleicht den Krafttest besser absolvieren. Dass man einfach solide Daten hat, anstatt dass alle immer raten. Und ehrlicherweise alle durchlaufen dieselben Lehrgänge. Männer wie Frauen. Das heißt, wir haben auch viele Männer, die im Frauenbereich arbeiten. Die haben diese Erkenntnisse hundertprozentig auch nicht. Aber auch die Frauen können nur aus ihrem eigenen Erfahrungsschatz irgendwie arbeiten und haben keine gesicherten Daten an der Hand, wo man sagen kann, so plan ich die Vorbereitung am besten, damit wir nicht nur 14 an Tag 1, sondern damit auch die meisten gesund sind. Damit die meisten eine ganze Saison schaffen. Also in Schweden waren wir damals schon deutlich weiter aufgestellt. Da hatten wir quasi eine hauptamtliche Physiotherapeutin, die die ganze medizinische Abteilung geleitet hat und die auch zum Beispiel Verletzungsprävention im Aufwärmen geleitet hat. Und obwohl wir damals schon auf Kunstrasen da gespielt haben, hatten wir weniger Kreuzbandrisse und weniger Knöchelverletzungen, als ich es in jedem deutschen Club erlebt habe. Und das hat mir einfach auch nochmal gezeigt, wenn man das ganze wissenschaftlich, datenbasiert, medizinisch angeht, dann muss es nicht so sein. Es ist nicht so, als wäre der weibliche Körper nicht gemacht für solche Belastungen und würde automatisch darunter zerbrechen, sondern die Bedingungen haben Einfluss darauf, wie viele Spiele wir pro Saison schaffen. Und alles, was dann da einfach so ausprobiert wird, ist eigentlich fahrlässig und ist einfach wirklich ein Versuch am lebenden Objekt.
Es sind so viele Themen. Wir werden auch nicht mal alle Themen hier ansprechen können in dem Gespräch. Aber gut, eigentlich war es fast zu erwarten. Es ist auch ein bisschen so ein Rasenfunk-Thema. Aber die Leute sollen ja auf jeden Fall eure Bücher lesen. Ich habe sie noch gar nicht namentlich genannt. Also Kathrins Buch, Wir verdienen mehr. Könnt ihr jetzt schon vorbestellen. Links und so weiter natürlich sowieso in den Shownotes. Und Lena's Buch Aufstiegskampf vom Seitenrand in die Primetime. Ich habe es zu kurz in die Kamera gehalten. Da sieht man, dass ich kein Fernsehen mache. Das könnt ihr ab dem 12.4. kaufen. Also jetzt, wenn ihr das hört, dann ist das schon erhältlich. Wird natürlich auch verlinkt in den Shownotes. Lena, ich würde noch ganz gerne mit dir kurz noch über das sprechen, was du dann eben bei deinem Wechsel in den Journalismus erlebt hast. Denn da musste auch wieder einiges zusammenkommen, dass wir dich vor einer Fernsehkamera jetzt regelmäßig zu sehen bekommen. Und wenn man dich aber regelmäßig vor einer Fernsehkamera sieht, dann versteht man das gar nicht, weil du bist da so souverän und schlau und witzig und so weiter und so fort. Ich meine, musst dich jetzt nicht weiter lobhudeln. Alle wissen, dass ich immer auch sehr froh bin, wenn du im Rasenfunk bist. Und trotzdem hat es eben doch einige Umwege gebraucht, um dorthin zu kommen. Wie viel von diesen Umwegen würdest du denn sagen, kommt auch daher, dass du eine Frau bist? Denn jeder, der es irgendwie geschafft hat in eine solche Position, der würde von sich sagen, ja, da musste da, das musste und der musste auf mich aufmerksam werden. Aber was glaubst du, wie viel Prozent oder ich weiß nicht, wie man es ausdrücken kann, kamen daher, dass du eben in einer Männerdomäne als Frau deinen Weg gegangen bist?
Ich glaube, Frauen in der Gesellschaft und ich glaube, in sehr, sehr vielen gesellschaftlichen Bereichen starten erstmal im Minus, während Männer in jedem gesellschaftlichen Bereich erstmal im Plus starten. Und bis du dich aus diesem Minusbereich zumindest mal in diese Nullzone katapultierst, dauert es als Frau sehr, sehr lange und braucht sehr, sehr viel Mut und auch sehr, sehr viel Stärke. Und du brauchst sehr viel Resilienz. Und ich glaube, bei mir speziell war das Ding, dass es ja Frauen im Sport und in diesem Bereich gab und zwar auch vor der Kamera, aber es gab eben immer nur eine gewisse Art der Frau vor der Kamera. Und ich glaube auch, dass es nach wie vor so ist, dass es zwar Frauen in der ersten Reihe in diesem Männer dominierten Habitat gibt, aber sie dürfen nur in einer gewissen Form existieren. Und so wie ich war und so wie ich bin, und mein damaliger Sportchef hat es mit den Beschreibungen zu laut und zu bunt auf den Punkt gebracht, ist es schwer, in diesem Bereich in der ersten Reihe zu stehen, weil das ist nicht für Frauen vorhergesehen, dass sie sich Raum nehmen, dass sie vielleicht selbstbewusst sind, dass sie vielleicht humorvoll sind, dass sie meinungsstark sind, dass sie präsent sind. Und das, was bei Frauen zu viel ist, ist bei Männern dann genau richtig. Anstatt dann als Frau die Zuschreibungen, die du zu hören bekommst, ja du bist manchmal zu cool, höre ich bis heute noch, du bist zu selbstbewusst. Das ist dann bei Männern halt, du bist schlagfertig und du bist eloquent. Und das ist eben etwas, wo ich sage, wenn wir echte Diversität wollen, wenn wir echten Wandel wollen in dieser Gesellschaft, dann muss es auch endlich mehr Raum für Individualität von Frauen geben. Weil du nur dann auch in unterschiedliche Lebensrealitäten reinwirken kannst, die eventuell normalerweise nicht in der ersten Reihe stehen. Und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Aspekt, warum ich auch meine Geschichte erzähle. Weil ich endlich in andere Lebensrealitäten rein möchte. Weil ich zeigen möchte, dass es auch als angeblich zu laut und zu bunt durchaus am Ende auch erfolgreich sein kann. Und dass man als Frau auch unangepasst sein darf. Und wir neigen dazu, überangepasst zu sein, um überhaupt Platz in dieser Gesellschaft zu haben. Also ich glaube, dafür braucht es Geschichten, die zeigen, dass es anders geht. Und ich möchte, dass Frauen endlich ihre Geschichte erzählen. Und ich würde sogar so weit gehen, dass ich mir nicht nur mehr Diversität hinsichtlich des Geschlechtes wünschen würde, sondern auch hinsichtlich der wirklichen Lebensrealitäten. Und das heißt auch, dass Männer viel diverser sein sollten in diesem Bereich. Dass da nicht nur dunke blaue Anzüge mit weißes Nikan stehen, sondern dass da dicke, dünne Menschen, schwarze, weiße Menschen, arme, reiche Menschen, links und konservative Menschen stattfinden dürfen. Und ich glaube, dafür brauchen wir viel mehr Geschichten. Und ich befinde mich in einem so elitären Umfeld mittlerweile. Und das beschreibe ich ja auch in meinem Buch, dass ich durchaus damit sehr, sehr fremde, weil ich mich überhaupt gar nicht zugehörig fühle. Und das bedeutet eben auch, weil da ich nicht nur als Frau mich oftmals alleine fühle, sondern auch als die Art von Frau, die ich darstelle, als queere Person, die aus einem bildungsfernen Haushalt auf dem Dorf groß geworden ist, die nicht Akademiker-Eltern hatte, die nicht irgendwen kannte, der in irgendeiner Sport-Redaktion gearbeitet hat, die ihr erstes Geld an der Rewe-Kasse verdient hat, die danach bei der Deutschen Post Briefe sortiert hat, während alle anderen Praktika beim Kicker gemacht haben. Und all diese Geschichten, die finden einfach nicht statt. Und die sind nicht sichtbar. Und ich glaube, wenn du wirklich Vorbild sein möchtest, dann musst du endlich deine Geschichte erzählen, die zeigt, dass es auch andere Geschichten gibt in dieser ersten Reihe. Und das war so mein Weg in diesem sportjournalistischen Bereich, der sehr elitär ist und wo ich oftmals und auch nach wie vor noch Schwierigkeiten habe, mich richtig wohlzufühlen. Und ich glaube, da muss man mutig genug sein, damit andere Frauen oder andere Menschen sich angesprochen fühlen und sehen, ach krass, guck mal, das war Lena's Weg und der hat irgendwie sehr viel auch mit meinem zu tun. Oder ich habe Anknüpfungspunkte. Und wir sehen ja immer nur die Spitze des Eisbergs und wir sehen gar nicht, was da drunter ist. Und ich glaube, das hilft für mehr Menschen wirklich Vorbild zu sein und die auch ihren Weg gehen wollen, die vielleicht auch nicht so gute Startvoraussetzungen hatten. Und nur dann können wir wirklich Diversität in dieser Gesellschaft abbilden, ohne dass wir die ganze Zeit ritualisiert über so Themen wie Diversität und Vielfalt sprechen. Einmal im Jahr, irgendwann, an einem Diversitätstag. Sondern das müssen wir auf diese Gefühlsebene bringen. Und dafür braucht es Geschichten und dafür braucht es auch Emotionen. Und ich glaube, während du Kathrin in deinem Buch viel über Daten und so sprichst, ist bei mir, also ich mache mich halt wirklich nackig so. Also all das, was ich bin, ist in diesem Buch. Und ich glaube, das brauche ich, um echten Wandel zu vollziehen. Und dafür musst du dich nackig machen, dafür musst du dich demaskieren. Und ich würde nicht nur sagen, dass dieses Buch junge Frauen lesen sollen, sondern das Buch sollen bitte auch alte weiße Männer lesen. Weil ich glaube, das hilft, um empathisch zu werden. Das hilft, um Wohlwollen zu haben für andere Geschichten. Und ja, ich glaube, so würde ich so ein bisschen meinen Weg dann auch in diesem Sportfernsehen beschreiben. Er ist eine bumpy road gewesen und er ist es nach wie vor. Und ich glaube trotzdem, dass es wichtig ist, dass ich da meinen Platz habe und ich würde dazu, also ich hoffe, dass ich dadurch ganz viele andere Menschen animiere, ja, ihren Raum in dieser Gesellschaft wahrzunehmen, obwohl er vielleicht für sie nicht vorhergesehen war.
Wenn ich eine kurze Sache ergänzen darf, weil das ist so absurd, dass dir gesagt wurde, du seist zu cool, zu schlagfertig, würdest du dem Experten zu wenig Raum geben. Eine Freundin von mir hatte sich beworben bei Sky für den Ricardo-Basile-Job, also als es diesen Job noch gab, also der Social-Media-Beauftragte der Konferenz, der dann eben die Instagram-Postings vorschlägt, und hat ihn nicht bekommen mit dem Argument, ja, wir trauen dir nicht zu, dass du Lothar Matthäus auch mal eine schlagkräftige Antwort gibst. Und ich kenne diese Frau sehr gut und ich kann euch sagen, also wenn es woran überhaupt nicht mangelt, dann an Schlagkraft, an Witz und an Eloquenz. Das war einfach nur ein vorgeschobenes Argument. Ich wollte das einfach nur noch daneben stellen. Und gleichzeitig glaube ich, dass da eben auch jetzt viel bei Kathrin noch mal angedockt hat, obwohl euer Weg sich dann so getrennt hat. Ich habe dich öfter nicken sehen, und es ist auch so interessant, wie sich eure Bücher ergänzen. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr müsst wirklich bitte beide lesen, weil es greift ineinander und man bekommt auch einfach so viele Argumente, wenn man Kathrins Buch liest, bei dem man in Zukunft immer sagen kann, ja, nee, stimmt nicht. Einfach jetzt mal dieses Totschlagargument, das lassen wir hier nicht gelten. Kathrin, ich vermute, bei dir sind jetzt auch schon wieder eigene Parallelen aufgefallen, bei dem, was Lena gesagt hat.
Ja, total. Und wo ich wirklich anknüpfen kann, ist auch dieser Punkt, unsere Geschichten müssen halt erzählt werden. Und dafür muss man irgendwo anfangen. Und ich habe zwar diese Daten und Statistiken gesammelt, um ein paar dieser Scheinargumente mal, ein für alle mal ad acta zu legen. Aber was ich ja auch mache, ist trotzdem meine Geschichte erzählen. Ich verknüpfe diese Daten einfach als Beweis, dass das, was mir passiert ist, nicht nur durch Zufall mir passiert ist, weil ich ein bestimmtes Alter habe oder in einem bestimmten Verein gespielt habe, sondern dass das der Beleg dafür ist, dass es allen passiert ist, über alle Jahrzehnte und immer gleich ungerecht und gleich sinnlos war. Ja, also ich habe einfach während meiner Karriere, ich habe ja dann nun mal einen Sprung auch in diesen Leistungsfußball geschafft, einfach festgestellt, dass so viele Menschen eine Vorstellung von meinem Beruf haben, eine Meinung zu meinem Sport haben, aber ehrlicherweise wirklich keine Ahnung haben, keine Ahnung, wie der Alltag als Fußballspielerin in Deutschland aussieht, wie der Weg in den Leistungsfußball aussieht, wie es ist, mit der Nationalmannschaft vier Wochen in Thailand zu sein mit 17, ohne eine Lehrkraft dabei zu haben. Ich hatte nicht mal einen Torwarttrainer in der Jugendnationalmannschaft oder Torwarttrainerin. Ja, und nochmal, wir reden nicht über 1982. Das war 2004. Ja, also wir wurden quasi mit dem Besten, als Beste des Jahrgangs zu einem internationalen Turnier geschickt. Und ich habe da vier Wochen mich mit der anderen gegenseitig wagen geschossen. Ich hätte ehrlicherweise zu Hause mehr gelernt. Ja, weil im Verein hatte ich wenigstens einen Torwarttrainer. Das sind so Beispiele, an denen ich einfach klarmachen will. Das, was ihr denkt, über uns zu wissen, wisst ihr einfach nicht. Ja, und ich bin trotzdem nur eine Biografie von vielen. Da sind wir wieder bei Vielfalt. Es gibt viel mehr noch zu erzählen, auch viel schwierigere Wege noch. Aber ich habe dann ab einem gewissen Punkt gedacht, egal, ich fange jetzt einfach mal an. Ja, ich fange jetzt einfach mal an, aus meiner Generation, aus meinen Vereinen zu berichten, weil ich weiß, für wie viele das schon repräsentativ ist. Und weil auch durch die Benachteiligung unsere Geschichten überall fehlen. Es gibt nicht die großen Bundesliga-Galas für die Frauenbundesliga oder die Ehrungen, wenn eine von unseren Nationalspielerinnen mal 60 wird oder die großen historischen Rückblicke. Es gibt ganz wenig Spielerinnenbiografien, ganz wenig Trainerinnenbiografien. Und ich dachte mir, wir müssen einfach viel mehr von diesen Geschichten erzählen, damit wir greifbarer werden, damit wir diese Emotionen wecken können. Die Lena auch gesagt hat, damit Menschen sich auch mit uns identifizieren können, aber auch damit sie wirklich eine realistischere Vorstellung davon kriegen, was für Hürden und Schwierigkeiten Mädchen und Frauen überwinden müssen, wenn sie den Fußball lieben, wenn sie Fußball spielen möchten und wenn sie im Fußball arbeiten möchten. Und die Hürden bestehen eben größtenteils immer noch. Ja, und ich habe keine Lust mehr. Ich höre seit 30 Jahren dieselben Argumente, dieselben dummen Sprüche. Ich habe keine Lust mehr, unter jedem YouTube-Highlight-Video zu lesen. Ja, und jetzt wollen die auch noch gleich viel Geld, nur wenn mal irgendwie ein Torwartfehler passiert ist. Ja, oder jetzt unter dem Nations League-Zusammenschnitt habe ich bei YouTube gelesen, auf jede von euch wartet irgendwo eine einsame Küche. Und da denke ich mir, so weit sind wir einfach noch nicht gekommen. Wir können gerne so tun in unserer linken Medienwabbel, ja, wo wir alle super divers sind und offen und so. Der breiten Fußball ist nicht so, glaubt mir. Ich war im November noch bei einer Trainerfortbildung, weil ich meine Lizenz verlängern musste. Da kommen immer noch dieselben Fragen. Da ist auch so viel Unwissenheit. Ganz viel Unwissenheit. Neben den Vorbehalten haben auch ganz viele einfach wirklich keine Ahnung. Und deswegen dachte ich, ich pack einfach alles, was ich weiß und was ich irgendwie belegen kann in ein großes Buch. Dann können alle mal nachblättern. Ich stehe für alle Rückfragen offen, aber wir brauchen so viele mehr Geschichten in dieser Öffentlichkeit. So viele Beispiele, so viele konkrete Wege, wie eben der von Lena und mir, an dem Menschen sehen können, eben wie hart es ist, aber auch wie interessant wir einfach sind, ist ja einfach so, wie du schon gesagt hast, die geileren Geschichten gibt es im Frauenfußball zu erzählen. Und da sind noch ganz viele unbekannt.
Und ich glaube auch schon, dass wir nicht nur dieses apokalyptische Narrativ bedienen, dass alles ganz, ganz schlimm ist. Ja. Und also, ich glaube schon, dass es auch wichtig ist, dass Geschichten erzählt werden, damit gesehen wird, dass auch wirklich Frauen in diesem Bereich da sind. Weil oftmals ist das ja auch so, dass man dann vielleicht als junges Mädchen denkt oder als junge Frau, boah, will ich überhaupt in diesem Bereich? Weil das ist ja alles so schrecklich und das ist ja so männerdominiert. Und dann, boah, nee, weiß ich gar nicht. Weil, wie soll ich mich denn da wohlfühlen? Und das hat ja auch eine total abschreckende Wirkung. Und ich glaube, wenn wir anfangen, die Geschichten, die es gibt, sichtbarer werden zu lassen und uns auch als Persönlichkeiten sichtbarer werden zu lassen, dann checkt man auch, oh Gott, da gibt es ja aber Frauen. Und da gibt es ja sogar tolle Frauen, die irgendwie aufgeklärt sind, die vielleicht die gleichen Themen haben wie ich. Und ich glaube, das schafft natürlich auch einen Anreiz für andere Frauen, doch in diesen Bereich zu gehen. Und ich glaube schon, dass es wichtig ist, dass wir das so ein bisschen mit Frauen, die schon durchaus in diesem Bereich tätig sind, aufweichen, dass sie mehr in die erste Reihe kommen. Und damit wir nicht nur diese böse Erzählung bedienen, da sind nur böse Männer. Ich glaube schon, dass ich mir da auch wünschen würde, dass die Frauen dies gibt, sich mehr trauen, ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen, damit dann auch wir am Ende nicht nur eine, sondern viele sind. Und ich glaube schon, dass wir uns da ein bisschen mehr in den Vordergrund stellen müssen und zeigen müssen, weil es gibt die Frauen in diesem Bereich. Und zwar ziemlich tolle, nur sie haben nicht immer die Strahlkraft und sie haben nicht immer das Spotlight. Und ich glaube, das sollte sich ändern. Und damit schaffen wir dann auch Anreize, dass es mehr werden.
Absolut. Und ich meine, wir müssen auch da, um nicht zu sehr da auch in Rollendenken zu verfallen, natürlich sagen, ich hatte unfassbar viele hilfreiche Männer auf meinem Weg im Fußballgeschäft. Und ich hatte auch Frauen, die nicht besonders hilfreich waren. Es ist nicht immer eine Geschlechterfrage, wie feministisch man zum Beispiel denkt oder wie innovativ oder progressiv man auch handelt. Da sind es meiner Meinung nach bleiben auch viele tolle Männer im Fußball, so wie er jetzt ist auf der Strecke, weil er eben nicht passt, weil eben die Diversität fehlt, wie du gesagt hast Lena, weil auch Räume für diese Männer fehlen, sich zu öffnen, sie selbst zu sein und Spotlight zu nehmen. Wir haben ja immer wieder dann das Beispiel auch der homosexuellen Fußballspieler zum Beispiel, die es ja offiziell immer noch nicht geben darf. Ja, also auch da bietet der Fußball, so wie er jetzt ist, nicht genug Raum für Vielfalt. Und die definitiv da ist, aber die noch nicht sichtbar ist. Und ich glaube, die hoffnungsvolle Note, auf die wir uns ja auch beide einigen können, ist, es war ein steiniger Weg, aber es war definitiv alles wert, so wie es gelaufen ist. Ich würde nichts anders machen. Ich habe mich einen Tag bereut, dass ich Fußballspielerin geworden bin. Es war mein absoluter Traumberuf. Ich habe es geliebt. An den Tagen, wo ich sehr schlimme Schmerzen hatte, vielleicht nicht, aber am nächsten Morgen schon wieder, wenn die Reha angefangen hat und ich wusste, jetzt geht es wieder bergauf und bald kann ich wieder auf dem Platz stehen. Ich liebte den Fußball bis heute ab, ich habe das Trainerinnen-Dasein geliebt. Jetzt bin ich ja gerade auch in Elternzeit. Auch da muss ich fairerweise sagen, weiß ich nicht, wie gut ich zurückkommen kann als Mutter im Fußball. Das wird sich zeigen müssen. Auch da sind die Strukturen noch relativ unbekannt. Aber das Spiel an sich hat alles erfüllt, was ich mir davon erhofft habe und mehr. Ich habe keinen Tag bereut, dass ich das alles so gemacht habe. Ich würde mir einfach nur wünschen, dass die Frauen, die nach mir kommen, es ein Stück weit leichter haben und sich zumindest mit manchen Problemen, die man vermeiden kann, nicht mehr rumschlagen müssen.
Dann landen wir doch am Schluss dieser Sendung wieder bei dem, mit dem wir angefangen haben. Die Liebe zum Fußball, das ist es eben. Das ist das, was bleibt. Und vielleicht kann ich noch die eine Anmerkung dazu machen. Ich bekomme ja sehr viele Bücher auch einfach zugeschickt und gucke dann auch immer mal wieder rein. Das heißt, ich habe schon viele Biografien gelesen. Und ein großer Unterschied, den es gibt zwischen Biografien oder Autobiografien von Männern hin zu Autobiografien von Frauen, ist, Männer kommen immer am Ende in ihrem Schlusskapitel dazu. Ich bin froh, dass ich mich durchgeboxt habe und es war nicht immer alles ganz leicht, aber der Fußball hat mir so viel gegeben. Also bei dem, bei dem ihr jetzt auch gerade gelandet seid, aber bei den Frauen eigentlich, ich würde fast jetzt sagen, in jeder Autobiografie, die ich da gelesen habe, kommt man am Ende auch irgendwann immer an einen Punkt, ich würde gern meinem früheren Ich sagen, du bist okay so wie du bist. Mach das einfach genauso weiter. Und das finde ich total interessant, dass dieser Zusatz bei Frauen da ist und wir wissen warum, weil wir haben die Gründe dafür, darüber haben wir jetzt gerade gesprochen und es gibt noch tausend weitere und bei Männern fehlt das dann aber eben doch. Deswegen ist das wäre so der Versuch eines Fazits dieser Sendung. Ihr zwei, ich möchte mich ganz, ganz herzlich bei euch bedanken. Ich möchte noch mal sagen, bitte lest die beiden Bücher Aufstiegskampf von Lena Cassel und Wir verdienen mehr von Kathrin Längert. Es wird alles verlinkt. Man kann euch auch einladen und interviewen und auch da wird alles in den Shownotes verlinkt werden. Und ich wünsche euch nur den allergrößten Erfolg mit den beiden Büchern, die ihr da geschrieben habt und möchte euch auch stellvertretend für alle, die das lesen, danken für den Mut und die Arbeit, die ihr da reingesteckt habt, denn ein Buch zu schreiben, meine Güter. Also ihr habt so einiges durchgemacht in euren Karrieren, aber ja, ich sehe es. Man sieht es in beiden Gesichtern, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn ihr es gerade nicht sehen könnt.
Auch noch in deinem Gesicht, lieber Max. Ich kann nämlich an den Prozess bei dir ja auch noch dran erinnern.
Also deswegen wirklich beeindruckend, dass ihr durchgezogen habt. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank für die Zeit, die ihr euch genommen habt für den Rasenfunk. Danke Lena, danke Kathrin.
Danke dir, Max.
Vielen Dank, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, mit uns zu sprechen.
Also das ist wirklich das Allermindeste. Und ich danke natürlich am Schluss auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn ihr wisst ja, alles hier im Rasenfunk, auch diese Sendung ist nur möglich, da ihr den Rasenfunk möglich macht. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Auch deswegen müssen wir nicht auf Reichweite gucken bei unseren Sendungen z.B. und können einfach das machen, was wir wichtig finden. Auf rasenfunk.de, da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Geht auf jedem Weg, den man sich so vorstellen kann. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Kreisliga-Pellet, bei Kalle Pflipsen, bei Fred Eriksson, bei Jororo, bei Kette, bei Alex aus Gotha und bei Anna und Jochen. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. Wir freuen uns über Feedback auf diese Folge. Unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de findet ihr ein sehr schönes Forum, in dem man sich gut austauschen kann, lest die beiden Bücher von Lena und Kathrin. Ich möchte das als letztes Mal nochmal mitgeben und bleib dem Rasenfunk auch gerne gewogen. Wir haben auch andere Feeds, die ihr gerne abonnieren könnt. Wir sprechen über die Bundesliga der Frauen, die Bundesliga der Männer, in der Ligatur über den zweiten Männerliga-Fußball und im Nationalteams-Feed über alle deutschen Nationalteams. In diesem Sinne macht's gut.
Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.